this week's news very obviously there
which you know we have to come to trumps
sort of ban on people from some Muslim
countries coming being able to visit
your head office so you must have people
who are affected by that what's your
reaction to it
oh look so what you know I sent
something out trying to all of our
employees because we have a lot of
people that live outside the United
States and they're concerned they're
afraid of what's going on so you know we
we we speak out to say gosh we think we
understand that safety is really
important but we also want to be able to
work with the people that work for GE
and allow them to so travel in and out
of the United States you have you oppose
the ban yeah no we you know we kind of
said we understand the context safety
but we think there's may be better ways
to do it and we're not we're not opposed
to speaking out on that but you know
yesterday the president sent out a
executive order that said two
regulations have to be cancelled for
every one that gets added I'm all for
the right so so I think to free we're
sticking all of the negatives well
without standing back and saying look
there's some directions he's going in
that are gonna be very good for business
I mean isn't it isn't isn't it
underneath it I sort of threat to all
the advantages that GE is built up you
know you have you have specialized in
hiring talent from around the world
pretty much irrespective of nationality
I think you've got sixty eight that's
sixty to sixty two percent of your
workforce come outside
yeah surely this sort of limitation on
it is something that I think if you look
there's a standpoint I think we're
running the play that the president has
outlined we're a huge exporter we're a
small importer really I think the things
that the president talks about really
are more talking to the people that are
importing lots of products and exporting
nothing so I think our play kind of fits
the play the president wants to run and
therefore I think it's up to me to speak
about how important it is that the US
have good relations with our potential
customers around the world and and we
have people there you know you know
generally people there on the ground
that there are Iraqis or Saudis or or
Italians or things like that
and
and they can help us I think with our
local customers provide that local phase
is is there anything in terms of
building walls with Mexico or anything
to do with in terms of this sort of ban
on people coming in does any of that
help manufacturing I I think that
philosophically you know we believe in
trade we believe in the free flow of
goods inherently we don't think things
like walls are good ideas let's put that
so so that's that's the maybe the macro
answer at the same time you know what I
would say is there's nothing wrong with
President Trump wanting to add
manufacturing jobs in the United States
the president China was said
manufacturing jobs the president Mexico
wants add manufacturing jobs the
president German or the Chancellor of
Germany wants to add manufacturing jobs
so I think he's thrust on how do we help
exporters how do we help exporters how
do we find ways to help exports I think
that's a good thing what about the
relationship with China is it's the
prospect of any kind of trade dispute
with China does that worry you at all so
it doesn't so not just G in the GE card
yes I think in the economic context
there's no good case we made with the
two biggest economies on earth being in
a trade war III think that relationship
a bilateral relationship between the US
and China is significantly important for
the whole world and so that's one that I
would be very strong on the issue of
deregulation and the issue particularly
of corporate tax is that something where
you you know is there a from America's
point of view first not just some G's
but from America's point of view is
there something you particularly want
him to do in that in that field
well look I think it's a place where
you're going to have different camps and
business who have different you know I I
respect Walmart but we're gonna have a
different perspective on tax reform
because Walmart doesn't mean they're a
bad company or G's good or vice versa
we're gonna have a different starting
point as it maintains that so I think
all of our voices need to be heard but
if the president can't act on tax reform
with Republican Congress and Republican
presidency that is a big Mis
for where we are right now and then I
think our regulations look the fact is
regulations have exploded now we need
regulations you had the joys of brexit
you now got the possibilities of lepen
what what you know are you still
confident about the future of Europe
you've invested very heavily that we've
never looked at Europe as Europe we we
know the difference between France and
Germany you know when we were doing
awesome in 2014 we were stopped in Paris
by a set of decisions that basically
violated brussels rules and we're kind
of sitting there as a American company
sucking our thumb in Paris and we had to
fight our way out of Paris then we had
to fight our way out of Brussels that it
didn't feel like the European Union at
that time so we've learned how to manage
paradox as a company we've learned how
to we learn how to manage subtlety as a
company and that's what global is a you
know globalization people that see
globalization from 30,000 feet at a
resort or in a townhouse or a think tank
don't know a damn thing about the way
globalization really works today it's
country by country deal by deal now I
wish it was all like free trade and all
that other stuff that's just not where
we are